Mike and beavis and butt-head are all
here to promote the movie which is
coming out which I'm sure will do very
well hide the movie come about guys Wow
I will refer to Mike for that's a
question well Michael the funny thing is
the funny thing is that from what I know
is the movie studio wanted to use real
actors instead of like the cartoons
which would have been a major mistake
that's what I'm asking did somebody come
to them with the idea of doing beavis
and butthead the movie yeah they
approached us got a week or two after
the show went on the air actually oh
really
they know what that was all for
live-action really yeah who do they want
to play beavis and butthead
like David Geffen wanted to cast
unknowns just fine 14 year olds
somewhere that would have been the
biggest bomb in the history of movies
yeah yeah two guys is beavis and
butt-head which everyone would have said
it was like a Wayne's World or something
it wouldn't been them you would had end
up looping all the voices in or
something so lame yeah that would have I
think it would have sucked yeah yeah
Mike hasn't had an easy career so what
happened with that did you turn it down
or yeah I just I just didn't I said that
I don't want to write the screenplay or
do anything if it's gonna be live action
but they had a right to do it even oh
yeah
mike has no rights to be somebody that's
why I love Mike story whether he could
have just nixed that idea Mike's like
the guys who created Superman
they died poor person it's a pretty
great story because what happened
you've told the story on the air before
but so Mike gets out of like college or
something right yeah well actually it
was I'd been out of college for a while
yeah I was just making animated shorts
yeah I mean he had you know he had this
whole thing gonna be with somebody and
it's like he some guy wanted it wasn't
even MTV some guy was gonna show his
cartoon at some convention or something
right so he signed away the rights to
that guy right no that's not no that
people from colossal pictures colossal
wanted to run it in liquid television I
didn't sign they wanted to but I don't
and then I held out and then I signed it
away to MTV
remember no nobody owns Matt Groening
doesn't own the Simpsons Chuck Jones and
I mean that's okay I just think when you
create something as unique as beavis and
butt-head you should get some
payday somewhere because what are the
odds are never doing that yeah there's
some I've gotten some paydays since we
last talked but what are you doing with
all this merchandising - you're getting
a piece of that I'm doing an audit right
now actually are you really yeah he's
not drawing pictures anymore
he's auditing because I've never seen I
have never seen so much stuff look at
this this is this is beavis and
butt-head aftershave are you kidding
yeah that came out this year yeah this
is a Butthead haven't seen it it's like
this is Beavis yet I've seen it on the
Howard Stern Show this is a beavis and
butthead CD holder now you see like I
know like with my image you couldn't
make a Beavis you could make it Howard
Stern CD holder unless I said okay to it
but would mic is I guess it's a screwy
deal that they can make it comes out
he's going oh I didn't know that exists
that you using title to getting anything
off the CD crate yeah look a look at
that one and this is the aftershave he's
gotta examine this oh yeah they put my
name on it
hey thing yeah they send all the stuff
to me but there's so much stuff well
supposedly actually I never saw them you
would probably like to see less of this
kind of stuff right I mean you would
like to consider because there's a lot
of stuff that goes out with like
captions that are really dumb that I
didn't and it looks like really bad
panel cartoons I mean yeah a good
example right there yeah right who had
the who had the rights to this this is a
beavis this is the beavis and butt-head
I don't mean to upset you
TV talker by Winfield you put it on your
TV on top of your TV okay then it's got
like a little riding on same crap on
every channel
shut up fartknocker this rules this
kicks ass this sucks there's no nudity
so I guess they got you saying that
stuff off the cartoon and they put that
in a box then here's a whole bunch of
beavis and butt-head books see now this
is supposed to have my name on it like
the other one yeah right
it's on the CD holder so what happens
who owns the rights to all this stuff
nowhere on here is my name
welcome to my club tonight not suitable
for children is that what he says the
product is not suitable for children
deadly gas yeah right so but will you
see any money from any of this stuff
yeah I've started to see some money
really I mean I'm I saw I got some
checks I mean originally I was supposed
to has had this deal that was supposed
to get me some money I was getting
checks for like $1500 yeah right just
sound like nine billion beavis and
butthead everything t-shirt I mean now
I've now I've gotten you know like some
sizable you have yeah yeah and but it's
really hard to know it may be this even
more you should be getting you get and
that's what you're doing the audit cuz
you can figure it out I'm trying to get
the audit done like B I was trying to
get it done before the movie comes out
though because it's gonna be an
explosion after the movie you hope yeah
and also so that you know so when you
get a check for like 12 grand you're
going hey this is great but some guy
might have made eighty million dollars
and he's living in bel-air
rich I'm a millionaire now yeah I mean
like the books and stuff you had
something to do with these yeah that
that one right making of the movie
script has a huge mistake in it there's
the the animation in the margins is
actually I drew every frame up oh yes
Mac cycle rightly animated that right
they and the head-banging cycle and it
gives credit to the three guys who
traced it and I just is he paying
attention to you think about this it's
been okay for a while but that these
were some there's been some who is your
agent Shecky Polanski all right may I
talk to beavis and butthead for a few
more minutes go right ahead
okay alright there stuff now all right
now do uh because I'm looking Mike
looking at that box that he has never
seen before
yeah I don't even know what the TV
talker is it's weird I don't understand
who owns the murders MTV on the
merchandising rights I said my name on
it
now let me ask you guys a question
because I've often wondered this when I
watch the cartoon and I'm wondering in
the movie will you show your wieners in
the movie they had to digitize b vs
wiener is that true really this is so
small now it's too big shut up on it and
what about the movies at rated R or PG
or what is the rating do we know is that
right so there's a little dirty talk and
maybe some nudity or anything the
cartoons nude you can say my butt twice
the full but the full butt crack yeah
and you can see on me you can see just a
little bit of my nutsack if you look
close is that really true